[Music]
in the 8th century seee
Viking surged across the misty seas they
came from Scandinavia in Northern Europe
but would travel far and wide some
plundered and settled in the British
Isles and France others braved Arctic
exploration or forged clever new trade
routes to the Middle East with their
steely navigational skills advanced long
ships and fearsome tactics the Vikings
sustained their seafaring for over 300
years
but for all their might they left few
monuments instead fragments of stone
bark and bone provide the keys to their
culture found in graves bogs and sites
of ancient settlements many of these
objects are inscribed with messages in
Old Norse written in runic letters but
the Vikings also scratch runes into
household goods jewelry weapons and even
shoes deciphering these messages is no
easy task
runes are short straight and diagonal
lines that make up an alphabet called
the fou sock all classes of people spoke
and wrote this language in many
different dialects there was no standard
spelling they wrote the individual runic
letters by pronouncing the sounds of
their regional accents some of these
inscriptions also bore the influence of
other cultures the Vikings interacted
with the runic inscription love conquers
all for example is originally a Latin
phrase from the poet Virgil many like
the enigmatic root rune stone were
carved in verse highlighting the
tradition of Old Norse poetry so even
though modern rune ologists can read
runes their meaning isn't always obvious
still in spite of the remaining
mysteries many inscriptions
memorializing the dead and recording
local histories have been deciphered
along with some containing magical
incantations the rumsen runes in Sweden
are carved on a rocky outcrop beside a
bridge for travelers passing over swampy
ground this causeway was commissioned by
a prominent local woman named C Garuda
she proclaimed both her importance and
her family's power by carving their
names in stone and even associated
herself and her family with mythical
heroism by carving illustrations of
Sigurd the
and slayer in the town of yelling in
denmark two standing stones from the
10th century memorialised different
generations of a royal family
the first was erected by King Gorham the
old in memory of his queen
3rd Ave and the second by their son
Harald Bluetooth after Gorham's death
the stones announced the power of this
Viking Age dynasty and they are among
the earliest historical documents of
Denmark they indicate that Denmark was
the earliest major Viking Age Kingdom by
telling that Harald controlled southern
Norway and he converted to Christianity
today Harald Bluetooth initials make up
the Bluetooth logo the 10th century
warrior poet Isle was a well-known
carver of runes
according to poetic accounts he wants
carved runes on a horn filled with
poison it's causing the horn to shatter
in another story are you'll saves a
young girl's life by placing a piece of
whalebone carved with healing wounds
under her pillow Norse poetry tells of
runic spells cast to ensure calm seas
safe childbirth and triumphant battles
but the exact nature of these spells
isn't fully understood many of the
inscriptions on swords axes and Spears
are indecipherable other objects like
the Lindholm amulet have inscriptions
that could be incantations riddles or
religious messages while it's difficult
to pinpoint the end of the Viking era by
1100 CE II there Seabourn expansion had
mostly come to an end however people
continue to speak versions of Old Norse
throughout Scandinavia and runes
remained in use in rural areas into the
19th century
today many rune stones remain standing
at their original sites the inscription
on the Danish Glavin group stone has
fearsomely declared for a thousand years
a warlock be he who damages this stone
or drags it in memory of another did you
know that the higher Sophia an ancient
Byzantine structure erected on the
Mediterranean Sea in 360 AD is decorated
with ancient runes how do they get there
watch this lesson to delve into this
fascinating history of one of the most
significant buildings in human history
[Music]